A lot of people look at Black Christmas and
find it scary because of how crazy and unpredictable
the killer, Billy, seems to be.
I have to disagree though, I have a theory
about the psychological motivation behind
his crimes.
Stick around to the end of this video if you
want to hear it.
[intro]
Black Christmas doesn't get enough credit
for being the trend setter that it was.
It was a holiday themed horror film, and it
opens with a point-of-view shot of the killer
looking through the house's windows.
John Carpenter would borrow this technique
for Halloween four years later, and Black
Christmas connected us to some creepy phone
calls decades before Scream.
We see in the beginning of the film that the
attic windows are dark, telling us that this
is the first time Billy has targeted this
house, which does play into my theory that
I'll touch on later.
However, this isn't the first time they've
received a call from him.
"Hey quiet, it's him again!
The moaner!"
So they have dealt with Billy as a caller
in the past.
"I'm going to kill you."
We see that the police station is located
at the intersection of Main Street and Swanwick
Avenue, and that places this in Toronto, Canada.
It still looks relatively the same today.
The cop cars are labeled "Bedford Police".
There are a couple of Bedfords in Canada but
none that are near Toronto, so I'm guessing
that Bedford is a fictional town and a slight
nod to the town Bedford Falls from one of
the most classic Christmas movies out there,
It's A Wonderful Life.
Did anyone notice Mrs. Mac brushes her teeth
even though she has false teeth in the cabinet?
However, despite supposedly having false teeth,
they still look horrible, and as if that wasn't
enough, she swishes her mouth with alcohol,
and not just any alcohol, but alcohol she
fished out of the toilet tank.
If you ask me, that's a lot worse than anything
the killer does in this movie.
The first kill of the movie is Clare, who
is suffocated in her room.
It's not shown how Billy gets her body up
the ladder to the attic, but there is a clue
in the second kill, where he impales Mrs.
Mac with this hook and uses the pulley to
reel her straight up.
After this, he goes on a rampage and knocks
over all of the things, while yelling at the
top of his lungs.
Later on after Jess has a minor scare downstairs,
Peter comes down and asks what all the yelling
was about.
"You scared the hell out of me too.
What was all the yelling about?"
It wasn't until I watched it for a second
time that I realized Jess wasn't making all
that much noise, and Peter was probably referring
to Billy's yelling, he just didn't know it.
Kind of creepy if you think about it.
After the cops start to connect the occurrences
of Clare going missing with the obscene phone
calls received at the sorority house, they
come by to tap the phones, so that they can
try to find out where the calls are coming
from.
We already know about two of the phones, the
one in the living and the one in the hall,
because Barb takes a call on the hall phone
because of all the noise around the living
room phone in the opening holiday party scene.
What we don't know is that there's another
phone in the house.
"Are there any other phones in the house?"
"Yes, the housemother has..."
"Yes, but it's another number and there haven't
been any calls."
This explains how Billy is able to make the
calls from within the house.
"Your phone's ringing."
"Oh, yes.
Excuse me.
Goodnight."
"Certainly, goodnight."
Later in the film, the soundtrack shifts with
the subject matter, going from jolly Christmas
to a much darker tone.
I guess Bob Clark really liked the sound of
Peter smashing the piano after his recital,
because it can be heard several times throughout
the second half of the movie.
*smashed piano sound*
"Claude are you up here?"
"Don't you tell what we did Agnes."
*screaming*
I've seen plenty of reviewers praise Black
Christmas for it's ambiguous villain and lack
of a real conclusion leaving them chilled
and uneasy and for this reason, I have to
include my theory about the reason for Billy's
crime spree in my Things You Missed.
Take this review on Culture Crypt as an example.
"Besides, how could Billy’s origin and the
killer’s motivations ever be more satisfying
than the disturbing nonsense of frightening
phone calls and the threat of unknown deaths
occurring behind closed doors?"
Well, maybe the happenings of Black Christmas
aren't as nonsensical as they appear.
The first scene Billy is in is the opening
scene.
As I mentioned before, we see from his point
of view as he skulks around the house and
looks through windows.
Staring through the windows of a sorority
house screams Peeping Tom, and we are quickly
given more evidence that the crimes are sensually
motivated during Billy's first phone call,
where he can be heard breathing, moaning and
choking before getting into laughter and snorting
like a pig.
Pig is often the word used to describe those
without restraint when it comes to sensual
subject matters.
From there, the language gets much more explicit.
It's no coincidence that he targets a house
of 10 women, nine of whom are college students
who decorate their walls with dirty posters
and give out fake phone numbers containing
"the newest exchanges", or in other words,
terms that are not safe for work.
You'll also notice that all of Billy's victims
are female, with the exception of one and
there's a reason for it.
They include Clare, Mrs. Mac, Barb who's taken
out in a very phallic manner, and Phyl who
dies offscreen.
There's also mention of something happening
to a girl in town a couple weeks ago -- could
be related and also the high school girl found
in the park -- again, may or may not be related.
The only male death is Officer Jennings, which
was only necessary for Billy because he was
interfering with him getting to Jess.
Keep in mind there are men staying in the
house throughout the movie, but none of them
are attacked.
Jess's boyfriend Peter also becomes a victim,
but Billy isn't the one responsible.
"It's hard to believe Jess would kill anybody,
much less Peter."
However, there's more to this than Billy just
being some kind of vengeful incel who decided
to ruin Christmas.
Like the Grinch.
If you pay attention to Billy's ramblings,
you'll notice he's constantly referencing
someone named Agnes.
He holds entire conversations in his head
with Agnes in which he plays both parts.
*Crying*
"No Billy, no!"
"The knife!"
"No Billy!
No Billy.
No Billy!"
*Crying*
The 2006 film has a character named Agnes
who is Billy's sister, but there's no confirmation
of that in the original.
However, we can infer that Agnes is Billy's
sister based on this scene later in the movie
where he's brought his mother into the fold
as one of the characters.
"Mommy..."
"Come here!"
"Mommy!"
"Where's Agnes?"
*Crazy laughter*
"Agnes!"
*Screaming and Choking*
"See Mommy?
There's the baby.
Baby alright Mommy."
He seems to be crying to his mother as she
attacks him, demanding to know where Agnes
is at.
From that, I would conclude Agnes most likely
is his sister.
In fact, Billy kind of illustrates this fact
by using Clare's corpse to create his mother
figure by putting her on the rocking chair
with a baby doll and using his hand to rock
the chair for her.
Using all the clues I've presented, I'll let
you come to your own conclusion about what
Billy is referring to when he exclaims, "Don't
tell what we did Agnes."
"Agnes it's me Billy.
It's alright Agnes, it's alright.
Shhh!
Pretty Agnes."
"Don't tell what we did Agnes."
You may still be wondering, why does all this
happen around Christmas?
Why has he waited until now to strike.
I think Christmas is a day that takes us all
back to our childhoods in a way.
It's the day that kids most look forward to
all year unless you are like me, then you
look forward to Halloween, but the point is
that you're always reminded of your childhood
on Christmas.
In Billy's case, remembering his childhood,
whatever abuse that might have consisted of,
brings up repressed memories and causes him
to revert to a childlike state.
This is the reason Billy sings the nursery
rhyme Little Baby Bunting after wrapping Clare's
body in plastic.
"Little baby Bunting.
Daddy's gone a hunting.
Gone to fetch a rabbit skin.
To wrap his baby Agnes in..."
He also throws what can only be described
as a temper tantrum.
*Screaming*
And I think the phone ringing at the end of
the film tells us all we need to know about
Jess's fate.
Let me know your own interpretations of Black
Christmas in the comments, and if you'd like
to see me cover the 2006 version of Black
Christmas as well.
This video is sponsored by the CZsWorld Merch
Store.
Pickup some merch for your loved ones, or
just for yourself even.
Just be sure to use coupon code 'DEATHMAS'
for 10% off all December long.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring that deathbell for
notifications and I'll see you in the next
one.
Assuming we both survive.
It's taken everything I have not to mistakenly
refer to Jess as Audra during this video.
So I think I'm gonna go lie down.
*phone ringing*
Take me off your call list!